ja diese Zahlen die sind verbirgt die EU
Asylbehörde gab heute bekanntes knapp
fünf Millionen Menschen innerhalb eines
Jahres Schutz gesucht haben jeder vierte
von ihnen hat in Deutschland sein
Asylantrag gestellt mehr als in jedem
anderen EU-Land dass die Lage für
Kommunen immer dramatischer wird zeigt
das Beispiel Locher dort sollen 40
Mieter ausziehen um 15 Flüchtlingen
Platz zu machen der Bürgermeister und
die Wohnbaugesellschaft sagen keiner
muss sich Sorgen machen alle bekämen
nahen und auch modernen
wohnraumangeboten ja das berühmte
allerdings die Bewohner in keiner Weise
so auch z.B die 64 Jahre Altenpflegerin
paulia lazarova sie sagte uns ich soll
15 km weit wegziehen und dann jeden Tag
zu meinen Senioren pendeln die brauchen
mich doch und ich kann mir auch keine
700 € Miete leisten ja Hecke mutet die
Stadt Lörrach diesen Mietern zu viel zu
oder muss man in diesen schweren Zeiten
dann solche harten Kompromisse eingehen
ich finde die Stadt Lörrach und viele
andere
die also mit solchen Plänen spielen oder
sie sogar durchzusetzen bereit sind
muten ihren Bürgern in der Tat zu viel
zu man muss sagen es geht ja hier um
bestehende Mietverträge ist auch
rechtlich sehr umstritten ob überhaupt
so eingreifen kann ist eigen der
Eigenbedarf der Gemeinden mit
vorgeschoben da muss man sagen haben die
keine andere Möglichkeiten gibt sich
andere Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten und
vor allen Dingen muss natürlich sagen es
geht darum dass Menschen die hier
arbeiten hier ihre Steuerzahlen hier in
Lebensmittelpunkt haben mehr oder
weniger mit der Pistole in Hand
gezwungen werden sollen Ihren Wohnraum
zu verlassen wäre das freiwillig tun
will wer sagt ich freue mich neue
schönere Wohnung da komm wunderbar aber
zu sagen wir haben keine andere
Möglichkeit dein bestandsrecht
gewissermaßen wiegt weniger als das
Recht der Flüchtlinge auf auf Wohnraum
das ist ein sehr starkes Stück es ist
allerdings muss ich wirklich sagen
tatsächlich ein Dilemma es gibt
sogenannte Flüchtlingsaufnahme Gesetze
das heißt die Kommunen sind verpflichtet
die ihnen zugewiesenen Flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen sei es in
Erstaufnahmezentrum sei es in diesem
Fall in in Wohnung das sogenannten
Verpflichtung das heißt eigentlich
müsste sich der Pro ist gegen die
Regierung gegen die Politik richten die
dafür zuständig ist dass solche Zustände
sich haben entwickeln können und die
sitzt eben in Stuttgart in Düsseldorf in
Köln vor allen Dingen aber in Berlin
solange wir sagen wir dürfen überhaupt
kein Zuzugs Moratorium Andenken sonst
einzige was wir machen müssen sondern
der Politik ist bauen bauen werden wir
ins in immer neue vergleichbare
schwierige Situation wie diese nein
begeben und ich befürchte wirklich dass
ich hier ein sozialer Sprengstoff
ansammelt der irgendwann sehr sehr ungut
explodieren wird und das alles muss man
ja sagen im eigentlich reichen Südwesten
da kommen auch Sie das Wohnen sie auch
jetzt heißt ähm hätten sie das für
Möglichkeiten dass man davor sollen dass
man dafür solche
Probleme sind sitzt Entschuldigung Herr
Boys habe ich in den Südwesten verordnet
Herr Kreis ich meinte sie hätten sie
können also sind alle im Süden
angesiedelt aber ich meinte jetzt noch
konzentrieren uns jetzt mal auf dieses
Beispiel eigentlich der reiche Südwesten
in Deutschland steht man hier vor
solchen Problemen dass man nicht weiß
wohin mit den Menschen hätten sie das
für möglich gehalten und noch dazu
gewinnt man den Eindruck man wird
sowieso nicht durchkommen mit diesen
Kündigungen das geht eigentlich gar
nicht da versteckt sich natürlich auch
der Eindruck ja da werden die Bürger
irgendwie über den Tisch gezogen man
versucht vielleicht auch seine Not auf
diese Art und Weise deutlich zu machen
also ich fand es auch für erheblichen
sozialen Sprengstoff was da gemacht wird
der Umgang aber ich würde mich die
anschließen was Sie gesagt haben das ist
ja von oben eingefädelt wenn wir in
andere Länder schaut
Immigrationspolitik von Kanada ein
riesiges Land ist ja die Jahrzehnten ja
das große Land Menschen holt wie die mit
diesen Dingen umgehen die gehen ganz
anders um die holen sich ganz bestimmte
Gruppen ins Land und auch in der
Flüchtlingspolitik kann man ja so oder
so oder so umgehen auch innerhalb
Europas gehen die Länder anders damit um
und der Precht unsere Regierung voran
aus welchen Gründen auch immer
moralisierenden Gründen also das wird
von oben eigentlich eingetütet von der
rot-grünen rot grün gelben Regierung
jetzt vor allem und die kleinen
Gemeinden müssen es dann eben ausbaden
die haben dann ja keine ein bisschen
mehr also jetzt auf Lörrach Lörrach kann
man sich fokussieren weil es da eben
aufploppt als Problem aber in Wahrheit
kommt es von ganz oben kommt es aus
Berlin das Problem und man wüsste da
schon überlegen wie viel kann man einem
Land zumuten an sozialen Sprengstoff für
die Zukunft welche Art von Menschen
wollen wir ins Land holen ich bin der
Ökonomen ernt andere Länder gehen mit
immigrationen Flüchtlingen also ganz
anders um als wir und vor Ort die
Gemeinden selbst sind dann relativ
machtlos wir haben natürlich auch
einsetzen oder dazu in Deutschland ein
weltweit nahezu konkurrenzlos Asylrecht
also der individuell einklagbare
Rechtsstatus des Asylbewerbers dessen
der sich um Asyl bewirbt ist natürlich
auch aufgrund der deutschen Geschichte
besonders weit ausgeprägt ich habe es
immer das vorletzte Buch von Herrn
Schulz gelesen damals ging es um die
Zeiten Wände und damit meinte er es ist
gut dass so viele Menschen zu uns kommt
das halt die gute Zeitenwende Frau
Merkel sagte ist stille Deutschland ein
gutes Zeugnis aus wenn wir für so viele
Menschen ein hoffnungsland sein also man
muss sowohl die Politik sprechen er muss
aber auch fragen wie gehen wir mit
dieser asylrechtsgrundlage um ja und wie
gehen wir jetzt auch das lassen wir uns
gerne auch auf diesen konkreten Fall das
ist ja kein Einzelfall haben wir gerade
auch gehört viele Kommunen schreien auf
sagen wir wissen überhaupt nicht wohin
wir wissen gar nicht was wir tun sollen
scheuen wir uns auch zu sehr danach
Alternativen zu suchen wie 2015 die
Diskussionen geführt wurde die
Turnhallen zu eröffnen Container zu
bauen geht man dieses Thema jetzt gar
nicht mehr an
naja ich habe das Gefühl das Problem
liegt auch
insgesamt bei der bei der bei den
Zuständigkeiten also ich habe jetzt
gerade auch im speziellen Fall Lörrach
das Gefühl die Lokalpolitiker schieben
das Problem nach Berlin die sagen da
sitzen die verursache während in Berlin
wiederum dann auf Lörrach gezeigt wird
und gesagt wird ihr müsst das da lösen
wir geben euch Geld jetzt macht mal
bitte und dann wird eben wie gesagt
nicht wie bei 2015 oder so wird dann zu
zu wenig nach gemeinsam nach Lösungen
gesucht also
wenn wenn alle die Zuständigkeiten
abgeben dann lässt sich leider dann dann
stehen dann die Mieter am Ende alleine
da will man auch die Bilder vermeiden
die damals entstanden sind
das das vermutlich schon und ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass jetzt gerade in
Lörrach sich da die die Verantwortlichen
das auch anders vorgestellt haben die
das geht jetzt in Zeiten der sozialen
Medien geht das ja ganz schnell das so
ein Brief dann eben im Internet landet
über Twitter geteilt wird und ich glaube
nicht dass sich der Bürgermeister da
gedacht hat dass der jetzt das sowas
dann so schnell die Runde macht ne also
und viele haben natürlich auch er weiß
die Befürchtung dass fördert natürlich
auch den Hass da spricht aber niemand zu
deutlich aus wir sind schon fast drin in
ihrem Thema aber glauben Sie dass es
auch hier der Fall ist dass man eine
Angst dazugewonnen hat das bloß nicht so
anzufassen bloß keine Parallelen
zuzulassen zu 2015 ja das kann ja gar
nicht gelingen ich meine die parallele
ist so deutlich liegt zu sehr auf der
Hand zu dem Thema hat eigentlich Kitzler
alles Wesentliche gesagt ich will nur
diesen einen Moment noch betonen dass
das wahrscheinlich genau den umgekehrten
Effekt haben wird nämlich das wenn sich
das nun häufiger wiederholt denn das
kann ja kein Einzelfall bleiben in
Lörrach das Problem wird sich überall
wieder stellen
dass ich dann doch ein ungeheures
Restaurant in der Bevölkerung aufbaut
und das irgendwann einmal umschlägt ich
finde die AFD hat schon relativ viele
Prozent mittlerweile wenn man den
Hochrechnungen für den Bundes ganze
Bundesgebiet folgen kann und die werden
gewaltig zu gewinnen weil dann Menschen
wirklich existenziell betroffen sind und
man nicht einfach nur durch moralisieren
an die Themen herangehen kann denn ich
glaube in der Tat wir stecken in einer
Falle so wir stecken in einer Falle dass
wir gerade was die Asylgesetzgebung
betrifft dass diese Asylgesetzgebung vor
dem Hintergrund des Dritten Reiches
geprägt worden ist dass unser
humanitarismus damals sehr gut begründet
war dass wir nicht mehr die Weltmeister
des Bösen sondern die Weltmeister des
Guten lieber sein wollten und dass wir
heute eben den Preis dafür zahlen müssen
ich bin nicht so optimistisch vielleicht
wie Herr Kistler das ist da zu einem
Umdenken bei der Politikern selber kommt
weil sich viele doch mit ihrer
politischen Identität an dieses Thema
wenden und ich glaube man wird noch sehr
sehr lange versuchen es einfach zu
tabuisieren ich glaube das war das auch
was sie angedeutet haben dass man im
Grunde sagt das darf kein Thema sein und
wer das thematisiert ist im Grunde schon
in Nazi also da ist auf jeden Fall ein
gigantischer Sprechstunde selbst als
Sozialdemokrat richtig glauben Sie dass
die SPD dieses Thema genug anpackt ich
bin ja als wie soll man sagen
Sozialdemokratie mich einsam geworden so
wie fast alles Sozialdemokraten die vor
20 30 Jahren sozialdemokratischer einsam
also ich bin eigentlich bei mir selbst
geblieben soweit ich mich selbst
beobachten kann nur die SPD ist doch
überhaupt nicht mehr wieder zu erkennen
so wie er die meisten Parteien nicht
mehr wieder zu erkennen sind würde über
die CDU haben wir jahrelang gesprochen
bei der FDP in beobachten den ähnlichen
entkernungsprozess jetzt in der
ampelregierung also wie soll man sagen
das was die die Mitte ist ist so weit
nach links gerückt dass man als normaler
Mensch automatisch auf der rechten
positioniert ist das muss man hinnehmen
aber wie gesagt das Problem selbst wird
ein gigantisches werden weil das
Restaurant etwas ist was ich erst wie
soll man sagen still und leise aufbaut
bis es dann mal zu einem Ausbruch kommt
der kaum mehr zu bewältigen ist SPD hat
hier meine sehr gute Tradition mal für
die SPD zu sprechen sie hatte ein
ganzheitlichen Sicherheitsbegriff für
immer gesagt innere Sicherheit soziale
Sicherheit und äußere Sicherheit müssen
zusammen gehen und die innere Sicherheit
hat sie leider fast preisgegeben da
gibt's auch keine bekannten
Protagonisten jetzt die jetzt für die
Sozialdemokratie die innere Sicherheit
nach vorne brechen und das finde ich
sehr sehr schade meine Hoffnung wird
daran wieder anknüpfen zu können weil
letzten Endes ist es ja die Kern der SPD
die auf innere Sicherheit angewiesen ist
die Arbeiter die Angestellten die
kleinen Leute die also nicht davon Düsen
können die nicht genügend Geld haben um
sich Sicherheit kaufen zu können und
wenn die SPD es schaffen würde
wieder als Partei der inneren Sicherheit
zu realisieren dann glaube ich könnten
wir auch neue Politik bekommen also ich
habe die Hoffnung nicht ganz aufgegeben
und möchte die SPD hier im Gegensatz zu
ihnen nicht abschalten wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall